on a recent day at jasmine's caribbean
restaurant the staff were busy getting
ready for what they hoped would be a
bustling dinner crowd
the restaurant which opened a year ago
is in the heart of times square and
christmas and new year's are usually one
of the busiest times of the year
but with new york now the u.s epicenter
of the covet outbreak owner jasmine
gerard says there is a problem
for all business i mean we all are
suffering at this time right now i mean
for me thank the lord i was able to open
up in the pandemic and i had an
opportunity to do so but everyone is
really struggling and we definitely need
people to come back to new york city
last month the biden administration
reopened u.s borders to vaccinated
tourists for non-essential travel
visitors have trickled back into new
york city particularly times square
but not nearly to the pre-pandemic
levels
according to local officials about 270
000 people walk through times square
each day during the month of december
that's about 100 000 less than before
the pandemic
and about 25 percent of all the
businesses in times square remain closed
many are restaurants look closely on the
side streets and it's noticeably quieter
just on wednesday more than 43 thousand
people in new york city tested positive
for covet 19. the numbers are rising so
high so fast that officials have decided
to scale back the famous new year's eve
ball drop celebration here in times
square from seventy thousand spectators
to just fifteen thousand and everyone
will have to show proof of vaccination
and wear a mask i think we're cautious i
think that
at this point you know we're keeping an
eye on the positivity rate but it's not
worrying us to a point where we're
stopping back at jasmine's they've seen
this movie before having struggled
through last winter's covet wave we were
able to survive at that time and then
you know where them out spread
broadway open
but now it's the sequel and another
coved surge taking its toll on times
square
and on its biggest night of the year
[Applause]
gabriel zondo al jazeera new york